well good afternoon to everyone
um i have a few thoughts about the trip
and then i'm happy to answer
your questions
as i have been both in guatemala and
here in mexico
over the last two days this trip has
reinforced
a central theme in the conversations
that i've had
both with the leaders of these two
countries
and members of civil society and and
people who have so much invested
in the president in the future and one
of the themes
is that there is no question that we are
entering
a new era around the globe and
this new era has made it quite clear
that we are interconnected
and interdependent that what affects one
country
affects the globe and certainly
when we look at the relationships
between the united states
and our neighbors in the western
hemisphere we know that to be true
the president and i feel very strongly
that what happens abroad
matters to the people of the united
states
we believe not only in the importance
and
and to our national security to our
economic security
to our well-being that it is critical
that we work on and continue to
re-engage
with our allies around the globe but we
also understand that those relationships
have an impact
to us domestically we understand that
what happens
abroad matters to the united states
and that is why the president will be
traveling tomorrow to europe
and why is my first trip as vice
president united states
i decided to come here to this region
and to visit our neighbors
in mexico now most recently and before
that in guatemala
on the issue of migration as we have
discussed
a bit during this trip it is a
complicated
issue it is complex there are many
factors
at play when we look at migration
historically
and currently it is also an issue that
we must tackle then
at every level in the united states we
are tackling it from the perspective
of not only what we must do
to address the root causes of migration
which is
the primary purpose for my
travels over the last two days and the
work that we have been doing for the
last couple of months
but we also must of course tackle the
issues that are inherent
in the situation at the border and what
we must do
to strengthen legal pathways
for people to enter the united states
i want to be very clear that the problem
at the border in
large part if not entirely stems from
the problems in these countries
i cannot say it enough most people
don't want to leave home
and when they do it is usually for one
of two reasons
either they are fleeing harm
or to stay home means that they cannot
satisfy the basic needs
to sustain and take care of their
families
i work with another principal which is
that
we as a government the united states
together with our allies and our
partners such as mexico
such as japan and south korea and and
all of those who are internationalizing
our effort
connected through the un we understand
and through our leadership we understand
that we have the capacity
to give people a sense of hope
that if they stay where they want to
stay
in the town in the neighborhood in the
place where they grew up
where they speak the language they know
the culture they go to that church
every sunday the place where their
grandmother lives
we know that if we give them
a sense of hope that help is on the way
that they will follow their first
preference
which is to stay at home during the
course of this
this trip i have met people from all
walks of
life i've met of course
with uh president giamate
i met with president lopez obrador
i also met with members of civil society
i met with youth i met with members of
labor i met with farmers
i met with young people who are creating
things that are
only a imaginable in fiction but they're
making it a reality
and what i know to be clear is that if
we are to address
the issues that impact the
southern border of the united states and
i've had a conversation with president
lopez obrador about also the
southern border of mexico
we have to have the ability to address
the root causes
of why people leave and we have to
understand
if it is a priority to us to be
concerned about what is happening
at our border then it must be a priority
for us to understand why people leave
and the reality is that
most people when they leave
they don't want to leave and most want
to go back
so that is the spirit with which we
approach these issues
i also believe that if you want to fix a
problem
you have to go to where the problem
exists if you want to address the needs
of a people you must meet those people
you must spend time with those people
because the only way we can actually fix
the problem
is to understand the problem and that is
another reason
for this trip over the last couple of
days
and for the work that we have been doing
for the last couple of months
to meet with people who range from ceos
and some of the largest corporations of
the united states
about what they can do to participate in
a public private partnership
to create economic resources
and possibilities for people in this
region
over the last couple of months we have
convened
some of the largest philanthropic
organizations
in the united states who are all
international in their footprint
to see how they can extend the work they
do
in partnership with the united states
government and the other friends we are
bringing to the table
over the last couple of months we have
brought together
civil society leaders both in the united
states and those of
guatemala and i was privileged to be
able to meet with them
after our first meeting that was virtual
in person yesterday
the work we are doing includes reaching
out through our un ambassador
linda thomas greenfield to the united
nations
to elicit to solicit support
and contributions from our friends
around the globe
to renew their focus on this region of
the country understanding the needs that
exist here but also the capacity
what has become clear to me during the
course of this meeting
and this trip is something i already
knew but has been reinforced
which we all understand
people have pride in the place they're
from
people have pride in the place they're
from
and so when we're talking about the work
that we are doing
we must approach it with an
understanding
of the capacity of people and not just
their needs
understanding that they have pride
associated with where they are from for
good reason
based on the history of those places
based on the culture of those places
based on the the the contributions
that those places have made for
thousands of years
so this is the work that we have been
doing i'm proud to report
that the agreements that we have reached
again are the result of all of the work
leading up to this
this week and they are very tangible and
very specific
do i declare this trip a success yes i
do
it is success in terms of a pathway
that is about progress we have been
successful in making progress
so as it relates to guatemala
out of that trip we came out of that
trip with agreements
to establish an anti-corruption task
force
this was probably one of the dominant
themes of my conversations
with the variety of people we met with
in guatemala
including concerns about those who are
in exile from guatemala in the united
states who i've also met with
inconvenience
out of the trip to guatemala we have an
agreement to create a smuggling and
trafficking
task force again one of the issues
not only there but here in mexico and an
issue i've worked on for a very long
time
in my career before i even reached the
senate much less became vice president
the need to address the fact that there
are some of our most vulnerable
populations
that are susceptible to abuse
and susceptible to fraud
and more horrible things as a result of
the smuggling that we have been seeing
from guatemala we came out of that with
an agreement to create a young
women's empowerment initiative and
dedicating
40 million u.s dollars to that
initiative
why i knew it before
and and this it is not unique to this
region it is an issue in the united
states as well
we need to do more as a globe and those
of us who have resources need to do much
more
to invest in girls and women around the
world
we came out of that trip with an
agreement
to supply 48 million dollars to
guatemala to support affordable housing
agribusiness and entrepreneurs
again i spoke of the young women that i
met with who are entrepreneurs
i will tell you that one of the biggest
basis for the economy in guatemala is
is agriculture if you have ever met or
know a farmer
you have met some of the most innovative
people in the world
because they have to adapt because they
have to be creative
because they have to be thoughtful about
creating out a city
of a situation that may be unpredictable
something that is productive
so we are investing in guatemala in that
regard
in terms of our visit to mexico
as you know i met with the president
this morning
we had a a long meeting both he and i
in person one on one and during the
course of our bilateral
meeting one of the first agreements
that we reached and there was a signing
ceremony is
a memorandum of understanding
on how mexico as a partner to the united
states
will with the united states focus our
resources on central america
and in particular on three countries el
salvador honduras
and guatemala
where we understand the capacity that
the united states and one of its closest
neighbors
i joke our first cousin our canadians
are also our first cousin
how we can work together with the
resources that we collectively have in
this region
to focus on central america we came out
of
the bilateral today with the president
of mexico
and his leading
cabinet members with an understanding
about what we are going to do in terms
of an economic
dialogue which is going to include top
members
of the united states cabinet working
together
with top leaders in mexico to see how we
can expand
our economic relationship understanding
again the interdependence and the
interconnection
between the united states and mexico
when it comes to our economies we have
seen over the course of history
that there is a direct relationship when
one is doing well
the other is doing well in fact with
pride i shared that
oecd just recently announced that the
united states is going to see an
increase in our gdp of 6.9 percent which
will be the
greatest growth that we've experienced
in 40 years
we believe this prosperity will be
shared
just by the nature of it and can be
shared
with our neighbors and in particular our
closest neighbors
we talked about agreements around
security
again the point about smuggling
but also the trafficking of guns
the trafficking of drugs we had a
specific conversation about fentanyl
and the need for security around the
ports in mexico
which the president is working on
understanding in large part it comes
from china
enters through mexico and goes north to
the united states
and for those who are in the united
states press you know
the damage it has done when it turns
into opioids
and the havoc it has caused in our
country
the interconnection and the
interdependency
we came out of our meeting today
also declaring and announcing today 130
million u.s dollars that we are going to
dedicate
to the labor reform movement here in
mexico
president joe biden and i are proud of
the fact that we will be
the most pro-union administration
we've seen in that way we see an
alignment
with the leadership in mexico and so we
took a meeting today and i took a
meeting
with leading labor
activists and and and professionals
lawyers and people who are organizing
people on the ground
to talk about how we can support
understanding again the interconnection
that we have
between the united states and mexico
when it comes to our labor force
so this is some of the work that we have
done um
the issues that are long-standing by
virtue of the nature of them are never
going to be solved overnight
but it is important that we make
progress
i remain optimistic about the potential
for that progress i also believe
that if we see the capacity of the
people
and if we invest in their capacity
we will see great returns on our
investment
so with that thank you all and i'm happy
to take questions thank you our first
question
will come from jeremy diamond at cnn
i have a foreign policy and a domestic
policy question but just to clear
something up that's been
you know in the news for the last 24
hours or so can you commit
right now that you will indeed visit the
u.s mexico border and will you do it
soon
jeremy let me tell you something yes i
will and i have before
listen anybody especially if you're from
california you know
i've spent a lot of time on the border
and it both going there
physically and aware of the issues
uh but the reality of it is that we
need to prioritize what's happening at
the border
and we have to prioritize why people are
going to the border
and so let's talk about what's going on
in the places that are causing the issue
at the border
i think it's short-sighted for any of us
who are in the business of problem
solving
to suggest we're only going to respond
to the reaction as opposed to
addressing the cause and that's just a
fact
if we want to we all know that in our
lives and our personal lives
if you want to deal with the effects of
of of a problem then you have to go to
the core of what is causing it
and so that is the approach we are
taking when the president asked me to
deal with this
issue it was about addressing the root
causes of migration
and the root causes are based on the
problems and the challenges
that people are facing in countries like
guatemala which is why i was there
and why i've spent time there thanks for
that you said repeatedly
that you wanted to provide a message of
hope yeah but you also came with a
warning you said do not come
uh and you warned that uh would-be
migrants will be turned away
why did you feel it was important to
relay that message while in guatemala
and are you worried that it may have
drowned out your message of hope
and then on the domestic policy front um
senator joe manchin has said that he
opposes the before the people act and
that he quote will not vote to weaken or
eliminate the filibuster
given senator manchin's position on that
and the current make-up of the senate
uh what what is your vehicle for moving
forward on voting rights in congress
and is it time for you to perhaps look
outside of congress for progress on that
issue okay
i know our capacity to give people hope
in
in that region and particularly those
three countries in central america
and i have no question in my mind that
the work that we have done
including the agreements that i've
announced today much less
what will come of those agreements in
terms of the work ahead ahead
is going to have a very positive impact
it may not be evidenced
overnight but it will have a positive
impact i
you know when we look at what is
happening in terms of
the experience of people who are fleeing
their home country traveling through the
entire country of mexico to come to our
border
it is it it can be a very
treacherous and dangerous trek
and i don't take that lightly
i don't take that lightly but the
reality of it is that
we have to address the root causes of
why they are fleeing
and and again i will tell you
over and over again with the people that
i have met during this trip who
represent a broad swath of people
of every stature every cohort if you
will
from the indigenous people
and representatives and leaders in
guatemala to afrodescendants to people
who represent
lgbtq individuals who have been the
subject of persecution
whoever i meet what they will say is
that ultimately they want to be
safe at home they want to be safe
economically meaning they want to be
secure
um they want to to to have corruption
addressed so that it doesn't impede
their ability to get the the resources
the government should provide to its
people
and so that's been the focus on the
issue of voting rights
the legislation is critically important
and we have been as an administration
the president has been unambiguous
that s-1 the the for the people act
needs to be passed the johnson's voting
rights act needs to be passed
what we are seeing around the country
our attempts to interfere with a
fundamental right of the american people
which is a foundation of our democracy
and by the way this is not even a
bipartisan issue
from my perspective it is nonpartisan
what they're trying to do these efforts
to suppress
or make it more difficult for people to
vote will
impact a wide variety of people whoever
they voted for in the last election
early voting
vote by mail drop boxes
those boxes don't have a signed democrat
or republican
so we're going to keep pushing for what
we need to do
to push back and and to stop these
efforts to suppress the vote
and to infringe on the american people's
right to vote
so there's the legislation there is the
work that we are doing will continue to
do of uplifting the issue so that we can
make sure everyone is aware of what is
happening
and that's about the bully pulpit that's
about elevating public discourse around
the issue
we will and the president has announced
this in terms of executive orders
we're going to encourage folks to
register to vote
and continue to remind people that in
this day and age i spoke earlier about a
new era
and the president talks about it all the
time part of this new era
is a debate that is occurring around the
world
about the relative strength or weakness
of autocracies versus democracies
that's real and one of america's
strengths
has always been that we can hold
ourselves out in the world
and then hopefully travel to places
where we have
some level of of respect because we say
that we are a democracy and we are true
to our democratic values and again one
of the most fundamental of them
free and fair elections people have the
right to vote that and it is unimpeded
so there's a lot at stake on this issue
that is about the legislation but it is
also about
fundamental rights and
so we're not giving up thank you our
next question will come from torini
party from the wall street journal where
are you
i'm in the backman
vice president harris uh in your
conversations on this trip
uh have you made any commitments to
expanding legal pathways for migrants
including work permits or for asylum
seekers to apply from their home
countries
and related to that did you come to any
agreements with president
lopez obrador on uh mexico taking back
more asylum seeking
families who are turned away from the us
on the basis of title 42
so we had discussions that were about
the need for example to re-examine
travel restrictions and there was an
announcement after my meeting with
president
lopez lopez obrador that you may be
aware of
where we are setting up a working group
to actually address that and and figure
out how we can move forward in that
regard
there was a discussion about also what
mexico will do in terms of increasing
its temporary work visas for people
entering mexico through its southern
border there were no promises made or
any commitments but we did have the
discussion
we did not discuss title 42 thank you
our next question will come from maria
fernanda at univision
thank you madam vice president for me
it's an honor because i actually got to
vote for the first time
as a nationalized citizen and i voted
for you
so my question is what would you say to
these women
those mothers and also women of color on
both sides of the border
farmers many of them who i see every day
as a message of hope but also as what
will you do for them in the next coming
years
that's a great question and thank you i
it was actually the subject of both days
and
a priority for me to convene women
leaders
to talk about exactly this issue um
and again this is not unique to any one
region
we can look around the world and see
that there is still
so much work to be done to fight for the
equality of women
to to to to fight against the
disparities that exist in
every sector be it education or the
economy
um and to your point to give people hope
in the process of doing that
uh what we saw in guatemala for example
where it were it actually was a theme
that is in the united states in
guatemala and here
access to capital big issue
are women given equal access
to capital to the financial resources
they need
to to invest in their own
entrepreneurship
in a way that they can achieve economic
health and success
it's an issue that we have discussed in
the united states in fact i'm working on
this as it relates to
our cdfis are community banks but it is
an issue here
as well so the work that we are doing in
terms of
our women young women empowerment which
you know young women of every age
in guatemala is about a number of things
including
looking at the issue of access to
capital the conversations that i had
there
included that women if they don't have
collateral
we're not given a loan but because of
certain customs and and the way things
work
out they may not have title to the
collateral that otherwise would be the
basis of the loan
there were discussions about the
interest rates that are being charged
here we talked just in this room um with
women entrepreneurs
about a very similar issue and what we
can do
to also use technology to get direct
relationships with these women it and
connect them with
financing institutions this is some of
the work that i've been doing
in convening the ceos in in the us
including folks like mastercard and
microsoft
who are interested in growing the
capacity in terms of their
digital health of these women so that we
can do online banking it's called
fintech
right financial in technology
[Music]
i will also say that
in my experience having done this work
for many years
there's a direct connection between that
and what we see in terms of violence
against women
so it is a fact that a woman will
endure almost any abuse
if it means making sure her children are
fed and there's a roof over their head
and one of the best ways we can ensure
that women have
power and agency in those situations is
to make sure they have
economic independence so they can make
the choices about where they are and
they don't have to accept a false choice
of either feeding their children
or enduring abuse and so when we look
around the world
we know that that is true and that these
issues are connected and so let's see
the interconnection because part of the
focus for us in this region is about
violence
we talk about safety and security when
we do that let's also
always remember the violence against
women and children
and usually disproportionately so and so
there are many avenues
through which we can address that and
economic empowerment is one of them
so thank you for that question our next
question will come from
monica alba at nbc
thank you madam vice president yesterday
you said you didn't want to focus
on grand gestures as it related to
potentially visiting the u.s mexico
border
and today just now you've stated more
definitively that you will be going
so can you help us understand how this
trip in particular to guatemala and
mexico
helped shift your thinking on that
position
in particular and now that you've seen
the root causes of migration and where
that journey begins for many
how soon will you go to see where it
ends for many of them as well
the issue of root causes is not going to
be solved in one trip that took two days
this is an issue that is long standing
is in many cases
generational it is not a new issue for
the united states
to feel the effects of those root causes
on
our shores it is not new
for us to experience that people will
come to the united states if they are
fleeing situations where they cannot
feed their children
so this work is the work that must be
done with a commitment
to going deep and making a commitment
over a period of time knowing that
nothing that we can do
will address it overnight so that is
my perspective on this issue and i
am committed to doing what is necessary
in the time that we have to
deal with the complexities of this um
it would do a disservice to the issue
itself
the issue at the border it would do a
disservice to the issue itself if that
is the issue that
that concerns some
to to address the root causes as though
it's something that can be dealt with
overnight
that's my perspective and our last
question
administration put out only seven
children separated
by the trump administration have been
reunited with their families so far
2100 still are waiting so i want to know
if that came up in your conversations
here
and if it's your sense that hundreds of
these may never be reunited at this
point
and will your administration potentially
support those separated families
to pursue a path to u.s citizenship
i believe that was a cruel policy
to separate children from their parents
and many of them very young children and
the president feels the same way and we
as an administration have made it
a high priority to reunify those
children with their parents
and
the way that policy was carried out when
it was carried out and now we're coming
in
after it happened is we've got to locate
people
we've got to um find people literally
find people
and we we cannot
give up on that and it's going to take a
lot of work but that work is worth it
and we'll continue to do it we'll
continue to do that
and our last question will come from
tamara keith at npr
oh yes i'll take the mask off hi so many
logistics
um i wanted to ask you a little bit more
about voting rights because that is in
your portfolio and there's been a lot of
news on it while you've been away yes
uh first senator manchin saying it has
to be bipartisan
senator mcconnell saying he won't
support the john lewis voting rights act
so how do you move this forward and also
you mentioned
um the bully pulpit yeah how are you
going to use your bully pulpit
on this particular issue
so voting rights
again one of the most important pillars
of a democracy
which is that a democracy is
truly a democracy if
all the people have the ability to
participate
a democracy is its strongest when all
the people have
an opportunity to participate and access
in this case to the polls we are weaker
as a democracy
when we impede interfere with or
suppress
that right to vote so it's important
that we understand what's at play right
now
and these laws that are being passed
are so transparently
going to have the effect
of impeding suppressing
and making it more difficult for people
to vote
so we're not going to give up talking
about
what the fix looks like and
the fix includes passing legislation at
the federal level
to have an ability to
reinforce and and to to reinstate the
the strength of the voting rights act
that's the john lewis voting rights act
um it is to to also put in place the
rules and the laws that we're talking
about as part of as
s1 the bully pulpit is going to be
important
we have a representative democracy and i
have to believe
and i i still retain faith
that when the people are aware of what
is in the bet their best interest
they will vote accordingly and when the
people are aware of what's not in their
best interest
um they will hold their elected
officials accountable
so using the bully pulpit using the
bully pulpit in a way that helps people
um see what is happening in the midst of
all of the priorities people have every
day
is going to be challenging but it's
going to be critically important
the power to convene you know there are
folks have been working on this for a
long time
so yes i i most recently have taken
a role of leadership for my
administration but i am acutely aware
of the people who have been fighting
this fight
you know for generations much less those
who are current leaders and have been
doing it for many years
so it's going to be about um contin
reinforcing the work that they have done
listening to them about what they
believe is most effective in addressing
the issue
there's a part of it that is grassroots
and it's going to be about
organizing folks on the ground to make
sure that people register to vote
we're going to have to be clear-eyed
that if these
laws are are continue to be passed the
fact is it's going to be more difficult
for people to vote
and so we're going to have to try and
you know let people know
hey you may not have that dropbox that
you voted
either to use last election may not be
there
there may not be any in within any
distance that you can travel
so these are the other options you have
all of those things are on the table
we have to i mean honestly
the bottom line on this is that if we
don't stand up for our democracy
i mean what do we have left worth
fighting for
seriously if if we're looking at an
era in an age where
the threats to
democratic values and principles are
real
where people are saying democracy can't
work
that it's not efficient that it's not
effective
i think most americans you know when we
raise our hand
and place a hand on chest and and and
and pledge allegiance
when we when we talk about patriotism
when we talk about pride when we talk
about the ideals
most of which we have yet to achieve but
fight for
we understand that the fundamental right
to vote is is one of the
the highest um
ideals and and and measures
of who we say we are so let's be who we
say we are
how about that
thank you everyone thank you everyone
five or six
that's fine